Unless you happen to
have a specialized ice machine in your home,
it is practically guaranteed that the ice
your freezer makes is of the cloudy variety.
A popular and well known trick to making clear(er)
ice is to either boil the water first or use
distilled water.
However, even doing this won’t guarantee
the kind of perfectly clear ice you’d find
in a high-end bar or restaurant.
This is because how clear ice is, is only
partially dependent on the purity of the water
you use, meaning even if you managed to procure
the tears of a Saint and pass them through
the world’s best water filter, you’d still
likely end up with ice that was a little cloudy.
So what’s going on here?
For those of you have the time, go to any
nearby sink and pour yourself a glass of water.
Unless you live in an area with bad plumbing
or poured the water into a dirty glass or
something, we’re going to guess that the
water is perfectly clear.
Sure, you may see a few stray nondescript
particles floating in the glass, but not enough
to explain why it looks like someone crammed
half a cloud into your freezer when you try
to turn that same water into ice.
The answer to this mystery lies in the temperature
of the water.
You see, at room temperature there are a lot
of impurities that are dissolved in regular
old tap water.
And as you may recall from high-school chemistry,
the warmer water is, the more of a given substance
it is possible to dissolve in it.
For example, sugar has very weak molecular
bonds that require only a small amount of
energy to break.
Thus, as you supply water with more energy
by heating it, the amount of sugar you can
dissolve within it increases and vice versa.
You perhaps have noticed this phenomenon when
sweetening hot tea vs. cold, or after letting
a sugared cup of coffee get cold, with the
sugar dissolving fine when it’s hot, but
showing up at the bottom of your cup when
the coffee gets cold.
This is essentially what happens with ice.
As you cool the water, all of the impurities
that were happily dissolved in it at room
temperature separate themselves from the liquid
and become visible.
You may now be wondering why these impurities
tend to congregate towards the center of the
ice cube, rather than being evenly distributed.
This is because as water freezes, it crystallizes.
This crystallization process generally rejects,
or forms more efficiently, without most of
the types of impurities found in tap water.
This results in the impurities getting pushed
into the unfrozen water towards the center
as the ice freezes from the outside in.
Eventually, of course, the final remaining
bit of water in the center will freeze with
the impurities having nowhere to go.
(This fact can actually be used as something
of a way to purify water, freezing water,
then melting it and keeping only the outer
bits.)
This is also why partially formed ice cubes,
where most of the center is still liquid,
are usually very clear- the water containing
these still dissolved sediments and impurities
hasn’t cooled enough yet for them to show
up.
So what exactly are these impurities and where
do they come from?
Well the most common culprits are lime (colloquially
known as limescale) followed by fluoride,
calcium and a whole host of other organic
materials that are practically unavoidable
in water (with many being good for you like
calcium and magnesium).
Heating, “softening,” or filtering the
water is one way of removing some, if not
most of these impurities and is partially
the reason that boiled and filtered water
often yields somewhat clearer ice cubes.
However, as mentioned, you’re likely still
not going to get a completely clear cube even
if you filter off the impurities.
So what else is going on here?
As the water crystallizes, tiny bubbles of
air form.
These bubbles get trapped within the ice like
any other impurity.
Specialized ice makers avoid this by freezing
water in layers to stop most air bubbles from
forming in the first place.
They also tend to freeze water extremely slowly
(setting the temperature much higher than
common household freezers) in order to form
larger crystal structures and to allow time
for any air bubbles that do form
to escape.